la gueule didier bonjour bonjour merci
de nous recevoir dans votre cabinet
particulier là où vous travaillez vous
êtes assez rare finalement dans les
médias tout le monde ne connaît pas
votre visage
en revanche votre réputation n'est plus
à faire est extrêmement connue en tant
que médium est ce que ce terme de médium
vous convient absolument absolument je
trouve que le terme de voyante vous
savez ces deux c'est ça une connotation
très péjoratif in a move saldana voyante
ça fait un peu gitane ça fait un petit
peu sorcière et jeu en fait le vrai
terme ces médiums d'accord et qu'est ce
que vous entendez par médium exactement
ce que je dis toujours que nous sommes
au fond d intermédiaire entre le ciel et
la terre
voyez nous sommes le lien espèce de noël
par lequel passent les informations les
messages d'accord alors ce qui nous vaut
notre présence ici c'est qu'il ya
quelques années vous êtes promenés au
petit trianon à versailles
et alors là à côté moi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé vous étiez avec des amis
absolument êtes jamais des amis et entre
autres michel de graisse qui lequel
avait eu l'idée assez extraordinaire je
veux dire sinon génial de me faire
travailler son enveloppe cachetée et
nous promenions dans les jardins nous
avions eus nous connaissions le
directeur de versailles à l'époque du
château de versailles et il nous a dit
on a eu la chance entre autres de
visiter le petit théâtre bien avant
qu'il ne soit
refait et là on nous sommes assis et
michel de grèce avec toujours la manie
d'amener un magnétophone et tout d'un
coup nous étions quand même dizaine de
personnes j'ai fait d'ailleurs sortir
des éditeurs qui étaient là parce qu'il
me gênait saison de me gêner away et
tout d'un coup je les ai vus j'ai vu
qu'il a ren ai mis derrière marie
antoinette et je les ai vus tapie dans
un coin ça paraît fou ce que je raconte
là comme disait quelqu'un journaliste
l'appelle la fumée de la moquette c'est
bien pas du tout et tout d'un coup j'ai
vu ce visa j'ai vu cette femme tapie
dans un coin du théâtre et j'ai vu je l'
ai vu je l' ai vu je l' ai senti et je
me suis mis j'étais pris d'une émotion
incroyable je me suis mise à sangloter
et getti elle est là elle est là elle
est là et michel tout de suite de
graisse amont chez son magnétophone et
elle s'est mise à parler à travers moi
alors c'est vrai que ça ramène un peu à
cette histoire des anglaises qui se
promenait dans le jardin et qui ont été
replongé vers l'époque
eh bien disons que j'ai vécu la même
chose mais à l'intérieur du petit
théâtre d'accord donc c'était un moment
j'imagine plein d'émotion c'était
incroyable je pleurais et alors
d'ailleurs il on a eu du mal michel a eu
du mal après à retranscrire ce que je
disais ce qu'elle faisait à travers de 1
200 réellement c'était la voie était
totalement changé d'ère c'était plus ma
voix c'était quelque chose de da c'est
incroyable je te dire je n'ai encore en
mémoire ce mouvement aux mollahs oui
d'accord et du coup vous avez eu l'idée
après alors à près de créer un peu son
on s'est dit mais il se dire qu'elle a
dit tellement de choses à ce moment là
que on s'est dit mais pourquoi pas en
faire un les valeurs je connaissais
entre autres notre cher franck ferrand
est un garçon merveilleux avec lequel
j'avais quand même travaillé sur des
énigmes de l'histoire et il a dit mais
tu sais ce qui serait bien c'est qu'on
fasse un livre sur la reine elle-même
sur versailles et donc il a eu l'idée de
de m'amener des documents sur lesquels
nous avons travaillé durant des mois
entiers et j'ai pu raconter tout petits
seins de versailles parce que bon il
faut dire que je lis mais je ne suis pas
du tout une historiette je suis assez
nul en histoire et je connaissais
vaguement comme tout le monde
l'histoire de versailles
marie-antoinette qu'on connaît mais
disons que dans les détails qui sont
dans ce fameux livre où il ya le
jardinier où il ya les robes les tenues
enfin toutes ces personnages
extraordinaires qui ont fait versailles
et qui ont été autour du roi et de la
reine
j'ai pu les voir les sentir ils ont
parlé à travers bon alors c'est vrai que
ce livre se témoignent ces témoignages
paraissent un peu fou mais bon pour
qu'ils s'y intéressent
c'est quand même très troublant dans la
mesure où franck ferrand je lui ai donné
des détails sur des personnages qu'il ne
connaissait pas donc ça c'était vraiment
une belle que lui-même le connaissais
pas qui l'a retrouvé dans les archives
donc pour moi ça m'a encouragé si vous
la continuer mais si je dois parler de
la reine
là on vous dit toujours mais qu'est ce
que tu as retenu qu est ce que vous avez
retenu deux plus forts sur elle bien moi
je vais vous dire ce que j'ai retenu de
plus forcés sont à vous en parlait
beaucoup d'un merveilleux
vous savez une pétale une rose du matin
déclaré shérif matt à cette espèce de de
lumière à l'intérieur mais quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ni le pommé translucide
extradé et je crois qu'après je crois
qu'on l'a dit beaucoup qu'elle abat d'un
ami et que sais-je et ça et surtout
aussi un autre détail très physique
d'ailleurs de détail très physique ses
yeux des yeux un petit peu exorbités
vous savez tout le blog le but lui et je
les voyais une porcelaine de delphes et
ses yeux comme ça donc je l'ait vraiment
et puis l'odeur aussi et ses banques et
à la danse c'est ça qui est fou c'est
qu'en fait vous avez des sensations très
physique attraits physiques c'est-à-dire
que lorsque je suis en état de
médiumnité pure et quand même ce qui
m'arrive même lorsque j'ai des
consultants devant moi c'est à dire que
non seulement j'ai des flashs des
visions mais j'ai des odeurs et j'ai des
sensations physiques extrêmement forte
par exemple lorsque quelqu'un est malade
un jeu g
je sens une odeur une mauvaise odeur
j'ai des odeurs site et ça c'est typique
si vous voulez de la médiumnité d'accord
justement marie antoinette à la fin à la
fin de sa vie souffrait du ventre
absolument et ça vous l'avez ressenti so
lu ment je voyais ces six couches
ensanglanté je voyais je le voyais et
puis je
j'étais dans la pièce c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire je la voyais se changer
j'ai vraiment vécu à travers ce livre
ses expériences ses personnages et
versailles quelque chose de très
puissant émotionnellement parlant est
très puissant sur le plan de la
médiumnité et l or pour revenir un peu
en arrière
comment vous est venu ce don comment est
ce que vous avez senti que vous aviez
j'ai toujours eu un j'ai toujours eu
parce que petite fille j'étais toujours
un peu particulière j'étais très
mythique je ne parlais pas du mien
rattraper et parce que je sentais des
choses et vous savez moi j'ai eu une
éducation très stricte
très résistant est protestante un peu
militaire un peu comme ça alors imaginez
qu'à l'époque la voyance en a parlé
panon tabou et c'était vraiment l'image
de madame irma donc et puis mais je
racontais toujours des tas de choses
j'avais toujours des hommes appelés la
petite sorcière mes amis entre eux à
leur entrée dans un magasin dit viens
viens viens parce que les gens après
aveu n'est donc j'étais un peu comme une
espèce entre guillemets de talisman est
toujours apte et quand même assez choyé
petit et puis finalement je suis arrivé
à paris à l'âge de 21 ans que j'ai fait
de la mode
et puis un jour j'ai vu une astrologue
qui m'a dit ma petite tu as des plus
beaux en voyant ce que j'ai vu elle
était fascinée par la voyance la
médiumnité way est une extraordinaire
astrologues et elle m'a dit voilà tu en
feras métier joaillier moins voyants de
la même et par an à l'honneur et puis
finalement la dc si ça marchera très
bien tu seras trés connu etc etc
mais je me suis dit je voulais vraiment
je re donnera ce métier ses lettres de
noblesse et je le ferai avec tout mon
coeur et surtout j'essaierai toujours
d'aider l'autre dans le sens positif pas
dans le sens du pouvoir
dans ce cas rien de pire qu'un médium
qui va prendre le pouvoir sur l'autre et
ça c'est ça ça va passer c'est
incompatible et je pense que si l'on
veut
justement garder cette qualité
médiumnique ce rapport subtil avec
l'autre
ce lien spirituel parce que c'est quand
même on parle d'un lien spirituel
il faut abolir son ego parce que j'ai
toujours la vision c'est l'abolition de
lego il faut complètement et surtout ne
pas et dans le pouvoir et je connais des
gens qui avaient des dos de voyance très
certain mais qui ont pris pouvoir qui
ont eu un ego surdimensionné mentionné
et ils ont perdu leurs dons je crois
qu'il faut rester toujours un peu naïf
un peu comme une espèce de deux ravis de
la crèche c'est un peu comme ça je me je
me sens c'est comme ça qu'on vous sent
d'ailleurs dans ce livre a oui parce
qu'en fait vous vous découvrez des
choses vous n'êtes pas forcément sûr que
ça soit vraiment parler comme ça vous le
décrivez
oui et on vous dit après coup ab oui
c'était sa relative rail vous donner des
pistes aussi finalement sacré talent
qu'est franck ferrand et oui ce qui
permet d'aller voir un peu d'autres
détails et donc d'envisager les
histoires sous un autre angle exactement
et c'est ça qui me passionne je voulais
donc j'ai d'autres projets avec franck
sur des recherches historiques ou des
lieux as oui j'adore les lieux la
dépréciation des le jeu reparle toujours
de ces lieux imprégnés d'une énergie
voilà donc quand vous êtes à versailles
ça vous arrive j'imagine d'y retourner
parce que deux dans les jardins ou de
vous promener dans le petit trianon la
grotte vous raconter à versailles quand
je suis allé ce n'est pas très
intéressant
donc j'ai eu la chance de connaître un
des directeurs donc nous avons pu aller
dans des appartements personne n'allait
mais je peux vous dire qu'à versailles
dans certaines pièces vous voulez santé
tous y sont tous là mais des personnes
des pièces qui ne sont pas ouvertes au
grand public d'accord je crois que la
présence à oui il ya des pièces fermées
dans laquelle je suis entré septs et ça
grouille est d'accord comme s'ils
s'étaient réfugiées là comme s'ils
s'étaient réfugiées là mais dans les
dents le trianon tout que les peuples
gens visitent rien n'y a plus rien c'est
rien et même d'ailleurs oui ce qui est
intéressant c'est que je suis retourné à
versailles dans le fameux ta femme et
tes atouts et quand il a été restauré il
y avait plus rien elle était partie
c'est marrant parce que je me suis dit
mais pourquoi tout d'un coup cette
histoire cette femme qui est venu
pourquoi est-ce que je laisse antilles
dont c'était comme une espèce d'appel
voyez ce que vous voit alors j'en sais
rien il avait des choses à délivrer
j'imagine
une grande tristesse déjà embrouilles ça
devait être très dur et je trouve qu'il
ya des erreurs et poignant je trouve que
c'est que c'est beau la façon dont elle
parle c'est pas si oui il ya dans le
vivre à elle elle a un langage une façon
de s'exprimer tout à fait extraordinaire
c'est beau les mots qu'elle dit et je me
souviens quand je parlais quand elle
parlait plutôt à travers moi j'avais
vraiment le sentiment que c'est plus moi
qui parlais à 10 mais vraiment j'ai lu
ce n'était pas votre phrase est dans
l'air voilà voilà que derrière on s'est
pas je sais pas une prise de position
parce que je jouerai ce jour extrêmement
lucide et même extra lucide mais une
espèce de je répète d'imprégnation comme
ça très subtil très forte qui se fait
ouais mais écoutez c'est passionnant ben
oui mais faire et elle le sait pas tout
à fait finie parce que vous avez
récemment sorti un livre qui s'appelle
le jeu divinatoire aux lardons il ya 20
ans mais il est ressorti il est ressorti
délai là depuis plus de 20 ans j'en ai
fait un autre qui est d'un jeu de cartes
aussi j'ai sorti beaucoup beaucoup de
choses entre dax et ce livre il a pour
but de permettre à tout un chacun
absolue de s'amuser parce que c'est
toujours joyeux et reçoit le joyeux
ludique mois-là savez on ne peut pas
comme ça a lancé des informations
n'importe comment je dirais vous faire
très attention qu'ils ont là devant soi
c'est important les raisonner sur et de
l'autre et donc ça permet à ceux qui on
envie absolument s'amuser elle a été pas
par la femme de michel de graisse marina
car hélas oui c'est merveilleux
voilà un jeu avec deux cas le jeu de
cartes et puis à travers ça vous pouvez
alors si vous êtes doué il est
il ya énormément de professionnels qui
s'en servent et est autrement beaucoup
d'amis qui me disent moi tous les matins
je me fais mon petit tour de carrément
oui parce qu'il est très positive quand
marie n'a passé qu'un tel m'a dit tu
sais j'y ai mis toute mon énergie
positive important l'énergie assure vide
d'énergie taillon sens bien dans ce
livre les énergies négatives et
positives gestion des personnels entre
voilà d'écouter un grand merci à mathieu
non et puis j'espère que vous allez
continuer à travailler
ou dans le dortoir oui j'adore ça je
vous dis avec franck ferrand nous avons
de grands projets bon ben écoutez j'ai
hâte qu'on en parle absolument avec joie
magali et merci à vous et à bientôt